thanks to brilliant for sponsoring a
section of this video i have a cold by
the way scientists keep making
predictions that the world will warm by
one or two or three or however many
degrees it is in 30 years time but why
do they keep making these predictions if
none of them have been correct so far
you may remember climate scientist james
hansen famously testified to the us
senate in 1988 that the world would warm
spectacularly in the coming decades yet
reality didn't match his predictions he
overestimated any warming by a factor of
at least two but what if i told you that
this graph has been doctored and that
the reality is much more shocking
come with me on a journey about
predictions i think you'll find it
interesting everyone knows that
scientists make regular dye predictions
about climate change some suggest that
they exaggerate the threat in order to
get more attention and so more funding
so in 2020 nasa scientists performed an
analysis of computer models used to make
climate change predictions specifically
they looked at the models used in the
fourth ipcc report which you could argue
with the most important models because
the conclusions of the ipcc reports are
the headline news of climate science the
authors compared the predictions that
came out of these models with nasa's
dataset of earth's surface temperature
and they found
that the models were pretty much bang on
the models closely matched observations
up to 2004 which makes sense because
models would know their models were bad
if they didn't match the observations to
date but impressively the models also
accurately predicted global temperature
increase from 2004 to 2020 which is
about 0.5 degrees celsius or in other
words all those predictions you've heard
in the news about short-term climate
change have been on average correct the
fact that the forecast period looking
forwards in time is approximately as
accurate as the hindcast period looking
backwards in time indicates that the
assumptions made by the models about how
the atmosphere will respond to changes
in greenhouse gas concentrations are
appropriate they're accurate the paper
also looked at older predictions
including some made in the 1970s being
much older and so much more primitive
you'd expect these predictions to be
less accurate but compare the warming
observed since a model was created in
blue with the warming predicted by that
model in red some models overestimate
the warming the red dot is higher than
the blue while others underestimate the
warming but for almost all of the models
considered their predictions fall within
the error bars of observed warming in
other words even old relatively
primitive predictions of future climate
change have thus far been largely
accurate and further each model here
represents the earth's system slightly
differently with some processes like
cloud formation or feedbacks and how
forests are responding to a change in
climate represented with different
numbers attached in the computer code
and this is why climate scientists and
indeed meteorologists use what we call
ensembles collections of statistical
models none of which are correct per se
but each of which are a good
approximation of reality combine them
together though and you get something
that is greater than the sum of its
parts not a perfect representation of
reality but a robust statistical model
of it something that we can use to make
predictions so if past predictions of
climate change have been broadly
accurate and borne out by the data which
indicates that our current predictions
are probably going to be also
why do we think of climate change
predictions as being well pants well
that has more to do with us as humans
rather than the climate models
themselves firstly any long-term
prediction needs definitionally a long
time to verify a prediction about what
the next 10 years will look like needs
10 years in order to work out if it was
correct or not by which point almost
everybody would have a forgotten the
prediction was made in the first place
and b forgotten exactly what that
prediction said you combine that with
the fact that science was within
statistically acceptable bounds
again isn't exactly headline news we
almost never hear of the long-term
verification of predictions perhaps in
the absence of verification we humans if
we even remember that a prediction was
made in the first place just tend to
assume that well it was probably wrong
add to that the fact that we as humans
are terrible at treating predictions and
indeed facts
neutrally psychology experiments have
shown that humans often only accept
something as true
if it supports what they want to believe
and something called motivated reasoning
we think this is because it's
psychologically easier to reconcile any
contradictions between the evidence in
front of you and your feelings on a
subject than it is to revise those
feelings that's something that takes a
lot of internal energy the predictions
made by climate scientists that the
world is fundamentally changing getting
warmer with more extreme weather are
scary and there are a lot of people who
simply don't want them to be true
and further there are plenty of people
who don't want those predictions to be
true because if they were
it would threaten their way of life this
brings us back to hansen's prediction
and this graph because
here's the thing
hanson didn't make one prediction
he made three
one assumed that greenhouse gas
emissions would increase exponentially
from 1988 one assumed that emissions
would increase but linearly and the last
assumed that emissions would peak around
the year 2000 and then decrease
comparing all three predictions to
observations we see that hanson's
scenario b
is pretty close and that additionally
hanson correctly predicted the pattern
of global warming with some areas
warming faster than others and the
arctic warming fastest of all in other
words he did a pretty great job yet the
hanson plot is frequently shown with
only scenario a the most unrealistic and
the furthest from observations and this
deliberate omission is done to peddle a
narrative that climate science doesn't
know what it's doing and that global
warming isn't real
and this is frankly
willful distortion of very good science
to further an agenda that agenda is to
keep things running pretty much as they
are right now enriching the people that
are currently being enriched mostly
through the burning of fossil fuels
the next time that you see this figure
being shared or one that makes a similar
kind of argument have a look at who is
sharing it why they are sharing it and
if you're feeling particularly motivated
where their money is coming from because
it's almost certain that ultimately
money is coming from fossil fuel
interest groups i've said it before and
i'll say it again go and read merchants
of doubt by nomia rescues and eric
conway it's really powerful stuff that
just might change the way that you look
at how global warming and several other
topics are covered in the news the
reason that we think climate change
predictions are pants isn't because of
the quality of the predictions but
rather which predictions we are shown if
you want to believe that climate change
isn't real you likely follow news
sources that only show you the
predictions on the extreme ends of the
spectrum either saying that minimal
warming will take place or that an
absurd level of warming will take place
and thus that scientists clearly don't
know what they're doing or of course you
can just take stuff out of context or
willfully misrepresent it that works too
ultimately though for the past four or
five decades the science has become
increasingly clear the predictions have
been borne out by the evidence
scientists predicted that the world
would warm and it has at the rate that
most models predicted it would
this may be an uncomfortable even an
inconvenient truth
but it is still the truth we are in
trouble whether you want to believe that
or not we can trust the science and we
can believe the predictions that our
models are currently making
so let's do something
together
to avoid some of the potential futures
that we see before us
do you find graphs like this quite
intimidating statistical literacy or
lack thereof is something that's been in
the news a lot recently knowing how to
read graphs like this one or being able
to see where statistics have been
misused like in this case or this case
or this case
my god has become an increasingly
valuable skill if you want to learn what
you're being shown actually means rather
than just being told then go and check
out the course statistics fundamentals
on brilliant who have kindly sponsored
this video brilliant is an educational
app and website that teaches you new
skills or allows you to freshen up old
ones through interactive courses the
idea is to get far away from rote
learning and memorization and instead
learn by doing introducing you to a
subject through interactive exercises
and getting you to do practice problems
give it a try based on your
understanding if you get it wrong that's
no problem you've just improved your
understanding by trying brilliant has
dozens of professionally written courses
on subjects in science maths and
computer science so if you'd rather
learn a new skill like python or
supplement you're learning in the
classroom when doing calculus there's
something for everyone i went on holiday
recently and actually tried out their
course on quantum computing on my phone
and it was really fun the app works
super smoothly and it was a far more
productive way to spend time on a road
trip than just playing slay the spire
over and over again to try it for
yourself head to berlin.org simon clark
linked in the description and if you're
one of the first 200 people to do so
you'll get a nice 20 off a subscription
for yourself or on a gift for someone
else that's brilliant.org simon clark
with thanks to brilliant for sponsoring
this video
thank you so much for watching the video
you can probably tell but i hope it
wasn't too distracting
i have a monster cold right now so in a
couple of days i hope i can look back on
this and see that it makes sense and
it's good because
right now i have no clue i'll leave you
by saying if you enjoyed the video
please do give it a like give it a share
if you think other people should see it
and you can check out some of these
videos right here if you want to see
some more climate change-based content
from me thank you again for watching and
i'll see you in the next one